nous continuons avec un sujet de saison
depuis plusieurs jours vous l'avez
ressenti le froid s'est abattu sur le
département les températures sont
souvent négatives et cette vague de
froid pourrait entraîner une
surconsommation énergétique qui pourrait
représenter jusqu'à 30% comment éviter
cette surconsommation les explications
avec vous osman vendeurs d et bien
comment éviter la surconsommation tout
d'abord il faut éviter d'utiliser son
four ou encore le lave linge ou
l'aspirateur pendant les heures de
pointe ce qui est entre 17h et 20h
ne pas laisser vos appareils en veille
l'art on parle de la télé des
ordinateurs ou encore de votre portable
des appareils en veille représente 11 %
de la facture annuelle d'un consommateur
et puis surtout ne pas surchauffer sa
maison quand vous n'êtes pas chez vous
il faut laisser la température à 14
degrés une fois que vous revenez il faut
l'augmenter jusqu'à 19 degrés et puis
une note en plus éteignez la lumière
quand vous n'êtes pas dans vos oeufs
dans la salle alors aussi quand vous
êtes à l'extérieur qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut protéger toutes les
extrémités de votre corps c'est-à-dire
la tête léman ou encore les pieds avec
un bonnet des gants et des très bonnes
chaussures il faut aussi usé de la
technique de l'oignon c'est à dire
acheter en gros un gros pull cela ne
sert pas à grand chose
il faut avoir plusieurs couches et des
couches qui sont près du corps et puis
c'est un point important il faut bien
s'alimenter on y pense rarement mais il
faut prendre des produits comme des
légumes ou encore des fruits c'est à
dire avoir de la vitamine c est beaucoup
mangé beaucoup de pâtes et de riz et si
durant cette période de grand froid
vous voyez des personnes qui sont sans
abri n'hésitez pas à contacter le samu
c'est le numéro le numéro c'est le 115
semaine pour ses différentes précision
on retiendra donc cette technique de
l'oignon pour ne pas avoir froid